this was a crazy story that I saw this  guy man was on a Carnival Cruise Ship  and he fell overboard dude this guy  right here  uh he fell overboard a carnival cruise  ship and he was in the water for 15  hours  what  imagine you just chilling on the boat  maybe you had a couple of drinks you  leaning over to the side and you looking  out at the water and you're like oh man  you know you trying to do the Titanic  you in the front of the boat doing the  Titanic I'm kidding  your ass falling in the water you the  boat just gone what's your first thought  you could get eaten by a shark that's  what I'm thinking I mean I would die  from the anxiety of thinking  I'm about to get eaten by a shark every  hour that goes by you think it to  yourself This salt water is seasoning me  up for a big ass shark to come eat me